Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today I will try to show
you the incredible progress
in computer graphics research through the
lens of bubbles in computer simulations.
Yes, bubbles indeed. Approximately a year ago,
we covered a technique which could be used
to add bubbles to an already existing fluid
simulation. This paper appeared in 2012 and
described a super simple method that helped us
compute where bubbles appear and disappear over
time. The best part of this was that this could
be added after the simulation has been finalized,
which is an insane value proposition. If we
find ourselves yearning for some bubbles,
we just add it afterwards, if we don’t like the
results, we can take them out with one click.
Now, simulations are not only about sights,
what about sounds? In 2016, this paper did
something that previously seemed impossible:
it took this kind of simulation data,
and made sure that now, we can not only
add bubbles to a plain water simulation,
but also simulate how they would sound.
On the geometry side, a followup paper appeared
just a year later that could simulate a handful
of bubbles colliding, sticking together.
Then, three years later, in 2020, Christopher
Batty’s group also proposed a method
that was capable of simulating merging and
coalescing behavior on larger-scale simulations.
So, what about today’s paper? Are we going
even larger with hundreds of thousands,
or maybe even millions of bubbles? No,
we are going to take just one bubble…
or at most a handful, and have a real close look
at a method that is capable of simulating these
beautiful evolving rainbow patterns. The
key to this work is that it is modeling
how the thickness of the surfaces changes
over time. That makes all the difference.
Let’s look under the hood and observe how much
of an effect the evolving layer thickness has on
the outputs. The red color coding represents
thinner, and the blue shows us the thicker
regions. This shows us that some regions in these
bubbles are more than twice as thick as others.
And there are also more extreme cases, there is
a six-time difference between this and this part.
You can see how the difference in
thickness leads to waves of light
interfering with the bubble
and creating these beautiful
rainbow patterns. You can’t get this without
a proper simulator like this one. Loving it.
This variation in thicknesses is responsible
for a selection of premium-quality effects
in a simulation beyond surface vortices,
interference patterns can also be simulated, and,
deformation-dependent rupturing of soap films.
This incredible technique can
simulate all of these phenomena.
And now, our big question is, okay,
it simulates all these, but how well does it do
that? It is good enough to fool the human eye,
but how does it compare to the
strictest adversary of all… reality!
I hope you know what is coming. Oh yeah!
Hold on to your papers, because now
we will let reality be our judge and
compare the simulated results to that.
That is one of the biggest challenges
in any kind of simulation research,
so, let’s see. This is a piece of real footage of
a curved soap film surface, where these rainbow
patterns get convected by an external force field.
Beautiful. And now, let’s see the simulation.
Wow, this has to be really close. Let’s
see them side by side and decide together.
Whoa. The match in the swirly region here is just
exceptional. Now, note that even if the algorithm
is a 100% correct, this experiment cannot be a
perfect match because not only the physics of
the soap film has to be simulated correctly, but
the forces that move the rainbow patterns as well.
We don’t have this information from the
real-world footage, so the authors had to try to
reproduce these forces, which is not part of the
algorithm, but a property of the environment. So,
I would say that this footage is as close as
one can possibly get. My goodness, well done!
So, how much do we have to pay for
this in terms of computation time?
If you ask me, I would pay at the very least
double for this. And if you have been holding on
to your papers so far, now, squeeze that paper,
because now comes the best part, because in the
cheaper cases, only 4 to 7% extra
computation, which is outrageous.
There is this more complex case, with the large
deforming sphere. In this case, the new technique
indeed makes a huge difference. So, how much
extra computation do we have to pay for this?
Only 31%. 31% extra computation
for this? That is a fantastic deal,
you can sign me up right away. As you see, the
pace of progress in computer graphics research
is absolutely incredible, and these simulations
are just getting better and better by the day.
Imagine what we will be able to do just two more
papers down the line! What a time to be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!